hua
[Aplausos]
bom dia há um mês essa apresentação com
uma provocação
podem as máquinas pensantes a essa nova
convocação minha é uma provocação do
autor e é considerado o pai da
computação o pai da ciência da
computação e no seu peito em 1950 um
paper publicado na revista mãe e ela uma
revista de psicologia e filosofia na a4
hoje exatamente com essa provocação
podem as máquinas pá é importante a
gente falar sp bola dentro de uma dentro
de uma linha no tempo para então 1950
aqui
o paper do dom antônio que tinha um
dólar a inteligência artificial é algo
que vem sendo perseguido explorado
investigado desde os gregos bom você ter
referências na tecnologia grega arroz 11
a ser existenciais assistentes e de
clientes a máquinas e telhas a durante o
século 14 15 e 16
várias e raios artigos foram publicados
sobre a intenção do homem em reproduzir
a maneira como o nosso cérebro funciona
a vale a pena colocar também nessa linha
do tempo acho que pouca gente sabe mas
em 1925 jack chan carlos controlados o
controle remoto ou seja 100 cem
motoristas rodando em nova york
a outra coisa muito importante é que o
termo ro e foi ele
em 1918 foi uma peça de teatro foi a
primeira vez que se usou a palavra
roubou a ao mesmo tempo o primeiro gol o
primeiro golo foi construído em 1955 o
que é mais interessante é que o termo
inteligência social por isso entrou de
água
a primeira vez utilizado em 1955 56 55 e
no congresso e 56 se trata pela primeira
vez na ciência inteligência artificial
de lá pra cá vários e vários a
crescimentos na ciência
contudo os dois grandes invernos hoje
que falam de verbas na inteligência
social porque invernos muito pouco
é importante falar em 1928 a primeira
máquina de jogo xadrez a e love e neutro
de pedro aqui foi em 1997 quase 80 anos
depois ou seja de longa data mas faltava
uma coisa que a gente chamava conquistar
é capacidade computacional faltava essa
temos hoje interligação faltava a nuvem
nos últimos anos de 2000 pra cá te dizer
se ao tem rolo ido muito acho que não
sabem como o oxi foi apresentado em 2011
ganhou um programa de perguntas e
respostas nos estados unidos
de 2016 o google ganhou do enxadrista um
xadrez chinês que ele é mais complexo e
mais complicado também
e hoje nós temos muitas empresas
utilizam emergência social na melhoria
da eficiência na melhoria a uma redução
de custos no aumento de produtividade de
fazer agora uma experiência no governo
a inteligência social funcionando hoje
aqui ao vivo ea cores vol
ah e como vai ser essa experiência
vou aproveitar o recado a pedir para que
um dos nossos jornalistas aqui do
durante a sua pergunta publicado sobre
um de seis temas é a primeira
apresentação é em mogadíscio acontecendo
aqui nós estamos a gente trabalhar mais
também despencou da minha avó que
gostaria limpa a gente tinha oito filhos
webb média por mulher corrigi los
o resultado é menos gente trabalhando e
tem que trabalhar por mais tempo bom
uma outra pessoa iria chamar o dia já
belo tudo bem
gostaria de agradecer o convite fiquei
muito 16/9 de 2017 12 ao clima
eu não entendi sentido favela com o sol
a pino
neste momento o céu está limpo a
temperatura agora é de 22 graus
o primeiro regime de previdência no
brasil ela data de 1888 mas o
regulamento geral da previdência social
só foi aprovado em 1960 a previdência
tem déficit que não pára de crescer e
que só neste ano será a próxima 400
bilhões de reais
na prática não há a menor chance de que
essa dívida esteja integralmente honrada
porque 251 bilhões de reais referência
dívidas de empresas saídas é necessário
fazer uma reforma na previdência para
equilibrar as contas
não é justo tirar mais de 400 bilhões de
reais por ano de saúde educação
infraestrutura segurança e outras para
bancar as aposentadorias e pensões assim
que os recursos da própria previdência
conseguem mandar a reforma da
previdência é necessária às contas da
presidência estaria absolutamente
equilibrada silva o superávit da
previdência fosse transformado num
aumento de benefícios i 1º cobrarmos
cada 100 ao devido pelas empresas
depois acabamos com a lei e inserida
acabamos com as mega aposentadorias de
políticos juízes e do ministério público
azul e é essa
ps recorda todas as regras o iss
aí tomamos todas as receitas verificamos
o local da instalação
por fim já que o supostamente a
previdência teve um superávit que as
contribuições sejam compatíveis como os
benefícios reter - o benefício de cada
um
dividindo o total arrecadado
proporcionalmente pelo que cada um
contribuiu assim haveria justiça para um
receberia de acordo com quanto
contribuiu os benefícios supostamente
recebe o lyon
eu aprendi com o ricardo
essas informações estão disponíveis em
ativos uma proposta irrecusável para
quem acha que o brasil não precisa de
reforma da previdência a vez da
indústria no interior a forma esquecida
extraídos do site e com a consultoria
ponto um ponto br
o expert no assunto entre homem e
máquina
ganha ganha novas drogas ou por isso há
uma outra máquina ainda mais exponencial
ainda mais policial hum hum onde as
máquinas pensá as máquinas podem
aprender a aprender com especialistas a
aprender com um ser humano
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]